[Musique]
bonjour c'est thierry votre conseiller
koffi frappe
on parle souvent de taux à 2% à 4% voire
12%
mais peut-on parler de pourcentage
lorsqu'on parle de liberté financière
faut en effet avec notre livret blanc la
solution est simple et efficace et
atwater tard qu'est ce tu veux j'ai pas
fini mon annonce
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce qui peut te
faire rester un tu tu veux quoi tu veux
de meuf à poil j'ai pas de me faut par
contre j'ai un super globe tu as vu il
est lu le nom à temps alors ok la meuf à
poil jallet mais sa présidence a vu les
bonnes on parle souvent de tous à 2% 4 %
voire 12%
peut-on vraiment parler de pourcentage
lorsqu'on parle de liberté financière
non non mais mes atouts mais c'est quoi
ton truc que tu veux je sais pas tu veux
la chanson peut-être dû du cadre et de
la chanson française
j'ai 4 et 5 avril et des gâteaux
[Musique]
maj et des figurines de papier dans les
corridors ok c'est pas vraiment cabrel
non non non mais attends tu veux quoi tu
je sais pas moi tu un chaton peut-être
un panier de chatons mais tenus par non
maintenant match est alors peut-on
parler de liberté financière lorsque
l'on veut parler de pourcentage
faux [ __ ] tu me crois tu veux ma mère
c'est ça tu veux ma mère tu que je puise
ma mère touche pas la gueule 1
alors évidemment on peut parler liberté
financière comment de paris nice 1 2 2%
des 4 % alors écoute moi bien hein parce
que moi je me buts j'en ai rien à
branler nous regarde ton skate jeu-là de
merde et que les perruques etc
non le regardant pense au mec que tu
viens d'ignorer
est ce que ce monde est sérieux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
soirée bienvenue en numéro 8 enfin enfin
le golden shoe numéro 8
voyez enfin parce que c'est vrai
qu'entre le golden chaussettes elle
connaît une chose 8 sais pas si vous
avez remarqué bien eu un petit peu de
temps un an
et des brouettes dont les choses ont
changé oui et d'ailleurs cette émission
un petit peu spéciale pour toute
l'équipe du golden chose ce soir
oui parce que les choses ont changé et
pour rémy notre cadreur les choses ont
changé radicalement puisque il est
décédé en thaïlande cet été s'il vous
plaît c'est une mort encore inexpliquées
mais on tenait à lui dédier cette
émission voilà et pour lui rendre
hommage et pour respecter ses dernières
volontés
ce soir le cadavre de rémy va est bien
cadré une dernière fois cette émission
merci d'applaudir rémy mais hamzé
messieurs c'est son meilleur cadre c'est
vrai mais ce soir des vies on n'est pas
là pour pleurer non ou alors si mais de
rire mesdames et messieurs prenez vos
après ski prenez un petit ticket pour un
téléski parce que maintenant
voilà une avalanche de sketches meubles
messieurs bonjour
pour pour un don de sperme salle 2
[Applaudissements]
rappelez moi quand vous l'aurez alors
excusez-moi je je suis dans la salle 2
et il ya un problème les magazines ya
que des magazines de chiens excusez moi
vraiment désolé si je sais pas facile
pour se concentrer
ça va mieux oui j'ai désolé a vraiment
non seulement leur machine bien j'adore
ce sera ce merci
[Applaudissements]
je suis crevée là il me coucher tu viens
non non je regarde un peu la télé peux
tu vraiment lui faire confiance
ne reste plus dans le doute date cocu à
8,50 14 54 s'allonger ça va très bien
mon amour dort bien toi aussi banni
[Applaudissements]
http de poids cela slash bonjour
bienvenue dans fast food le journaux des
réseaux social au sommaire de cette
édition une nouvelle tendance qui émerge
sur à ce bouquet l'invité du jour un
véritable mystère d internet mais on
commence comme chaque semaine avec le
truite de la semaine qui est signée
rodrigues perez qui nous dit si mon sexe
était une barre de métro je ne bouderai
pas tous les jours vu de sa femme
manucure ou le comprend passons tout de
suite à notre premier sujet concernant à
ce bouquet pour nous en parler et bien
c'est gilles manouche qui est avec nous
alors gilles qu'est ce que vous faites
bonjour et bien tout le monde connaît le
baby sitting ou même aujourd'hui le dog
sitting
mais quand vous partez en vacances il ya
quelqu'un dont on doit s'occuper aussi
et auxquelles on ne pense pas souvent
qui est-ce qui s pièces et oui c'est à
ce book la société s'occupe de votre à
bouque quand vous n'êtes pas là on
s'engage à déconnecter reconnecter votre
compte au moins trois fois par jour pour
décourager les voleurs de compte
justement incroyable ça c'est vraiment
malin alors comment s'appelle votre
service c'est l'alliance de haas book et
du baby sitting pouf le casting
le hastings est-ce que c'est pas
justement s'asseoir sur le visage de
votre wii bon effectivement au moment où
on a trouvé le nom c'est bientôt ça
permet un ami qui nous l'a dit mais bon
le bref j'en avais déjà acheté le point
comme on avait déjà sorti à l'inpi alors
on s'est dit qu'on allait sûrement en
parler à mon beau-frère ce qui n'est pas
société je ne parle pas du fromage
hashtag blague
même si certains vont en faire un de
freinage en tout cas moi je n'ai pas de
trous société un véritable mystère d
internet ils fleurissent un peu partout
sur les réseaux social et on ne connaît
pas leurs origines ce sont les osef
après une enquête haletante notre équipe
a réussi à trouver l'auteur de ces
fameux osef
il est là pour nous en parler c'est
nicolas futre alors nicolas pour que les
téléspectateurs comprennent bien de quoi
il s'agit on va essayer de rappeler
comment vous créer ces fameux osef vous
allez d'abord sur internet regarder une
vidéo ou un article vous créez un compte
vous vous y connecter pour laisser
finalement le message on s'en fou qui en
langage internet écrit joseph versa osef
orizet aux familles très bien merci
nicolas c'est la fin de ce fast food le
journaux des réseaux social
n'oubliez surtout pas de follow de fff
est fast food au d'être l'ami des ratons
laveurs
et ma famille
[Applaudissements]
ross dont deux jours tu vas voir tu es
rennes
[Applaudissements]
on adapte wyser pratte et jean jacques
benoît tiers des ingrédients naturels
mambo une recette authentique
on ne résiste pas un petit pot la
litière
la litière
au bout ça vous remet de pipi découvrez
aussi plus onctueux le nouveau la
litière ou kaka
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans votre
journal suite à la crise mondiale mais
nous subissons une nouvelle hausse
record du chômage avec 12 millions 160
9300 chômeurs supplémentaires la spirale
semble ne pas pouvoir s'arrêter
[Musique]
monsieur le premier ministre nous avons
un problème le chômage explose le
plancher et nous craignons des émeutes
dans le pays d'une semaine à l'autre
je fais on va créer des emplois comme
option ok
[Musique]
et
premières mesures du gouvernement pour
résorber ce chômage record la création
de 12 millions 160 9300 emplois d'hommes
objets pour mieux comprendre
regardons ensemble ce reportage de j
-luc seychelles depuis la mise en
vigueur de cette loi des hommes objets
fleurissent dans toute la france focus
sur ces nouveaux emplois comme thierry
qui est gps tourner à droite fait
demi-tour spa parle a fait demi tour
fait demi tour ses revenus ont fait
demi-tour infinie tournoi
sylvain lui a trouvé un poste de brosses
à dents électriques chez un couple dans
les yvelines
[Musique]
et enfin voici marc antoine qui étaient
en recherche d'emploi depuis plus de
deux ans il peut finalement s'épanouir
pleinement dans une activité de bar de
métro
[Applaudissements]
le climat économique était tendue mais
visiblement la courbe du chômage
semblent indiquer une baisse record du
jamais vu en termes de croissance
un pic historique et christian le mari
ma soeur lui les hommes cravate le butin
l'inter si les promesses du gouvernement
semble avoir été tenu
ces mesures audacieuses ne cache-t-elle
pas un autre problème
d'octobre monsieur le premier ministre
nous avons encore un problème comme le
chômage n'existe plus les quarante cinq
mille employés du pôle emploi et sont
sans emploi
pardon je sais on va fabriquer une
machine à voyager dans le temps on
faisait un bond dans le passé où aller
chercher les chômeurs d'il ya deux mois
elle est ramenée dans le présent ah ok
et donc la france est mystérieusement
surpeuplée retour au chômage avec cette
hausse record de 12 millions 169 fils
300 chômeurs malgré les mesures du
gouvernement
la spirale semble ne jamais pouvoir
s'arrêter voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal on se retrouve lundi passé un
bon week-end à l'est alain michel et
surtout tu sois une ton de 1 en tout cas
je trouve que c'est un très bon choix de
restaurants toi prends premier rendez
vous merci passe trop c'est une très
jolie rencontre
c'est vrai tu sais moi je trouves tu as
deux très belles couilles kipling qui
lui tellement que tout le [ __ ] et
c'est le fleith dedans je ne pense moi
en tout cas je le pense mais j'ai bien
mangé le monde est ce que tu me connais
un petit peu marcher dans la mouille
[ __ ] [ __ ] on va y aller vous prenez
les chasses restaurant voilà et c'est
comme ça que je suis devenu infirmier
j'adore quand les gens vont jusqu'au
bout de leurs beats j'adore paris c'est
vraiment une ville super même s'il ya
beaucoup de [ __ ] qui vole ça c'est
pas bien mais c'est parce que vous leur
donnez à manger qu'ils restent ici avec
c'est un très très bel sodomie pour moi
est vraiment une fille de joie
et si tu me laisses ton numéro de
bouffeurs de que moi je t'appelle non
excusez moi ça va ça va trop vite j'ai
besoin de temps j'ai dit quelque chose
qu'il fallait pas si c'est ça je m'en
fous je mens culte récents seulement
voilà bah on n'a qu'à faire ça on dit
que tant qu elle est l esaa bête val
futur annales
s'est passé comment elle m'a retourné la
table j'avais le gland qui batifole
corps mais elle n'a pas voulu marcher
sur la bouche tu sais est bien assis toi
/ spé des et raconte mme matoo commandes
il tient avant est ce que tu veux boire
du 1 comment tu appelles ça ça fils de
[ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que tout se passe bien
voilà bah ouais moi j'espère pour vous
que ça se passe bien parce que qu'est ce
qui se passe qu'est la police
scientifique
je viens à regarder l'adn du défunt et
il est là très bien je dis moi c'est la
police scientifique qui sont plus malins
que les autres
bonjour monsieur bonjour c
pas prévu non c'est un peu
on va être passée à des sketchs oui
alors on va on va regarder escaich parce
que justement va regarder des sketchs
vous les avez vu danser à ibiza vous les
avez vu se prendre au jeu à las vegas
vous allez les adorer à shanghai la
ville de toutes les libertés
[Musique]
le jeu
booba
les ch'tis à shanghai tu as pu pourquoi
ça pue là c'est quoi ce bazar des le
maroilles il est foutu la flotte partout
là c'est quoi ce même heure 1 mof hurle
marolles anos talayan est qu'elle est
celle attendue frigo ouverte ok
maintenant toutes les congèle de da elle
s'en foutent et comme on a shanghai je
vous rends pas compte comment c'est dur
de trouver du fromage au japon t3 bas
fallait pas que jordan et des zones ils
se battent pour des broutilles
c'est beau la vase immigrants à fermer
ton eau ya un nouveau jeudi qu'areva la
villa j'espère que le nouveau style en
vrille appâter le pâté quel goût et là
il arrive et on le voit
salut moi c'est jordan grotte appel à
mais oui mais je te connais tu es pas de
la famille à steve de tourcoing allez
tous à eau comme tout comme kia la sorte
hcg chantal lepot méchant le nouveau
mais juste il a des problèmes au niveau
de la halle a promis scruter août est
qui ce qui laisse traîner des merdes
comme ça dans la baignoire là haut c'est
beau rire voici un poisson pour le coq
jordan brian regarder chanial emmène le
nouveau dans sa chambre où s'opèrent en
volume est classique est un volume
additionnel ne dit que le tout il faut
toujours qu'il y de toutes les races et
tout ce qui vient d'ici
tout ce qui vient d'ici donc vous les
baies le chien ce mélo dans l eau ça va
pas du tout là ton truc c'est pas normal
ça va trop vite là ça pousse trop lente
normal des toits on est tous d'accord
pour dire ici que tu parle jamais et on
sait pas si tu es un vrai ch'ti hockey
et on ne sait pas si tu sais faire des
choses pour montrer que tu sais faire
des choses pour travailler dans l'ana et
ou pas alors qu'est ce que tu as à dire
des joies mais aussi des peines
une chose est sûre les ch'tis ne vous
laisserons pas indifférente à la rame
dans la main dans le prochain épisode
vous verrez comment ils vont combattre
la race alien qui est sorti du ventre de
shania que tu veux chauffeur bonjour
qu'est ce que ça sera pour le monsieur
en soule achever plein une [ __ ] s'il
vous plaît une [ __ ]
non juste à côté une [ __ ] oui et je vous
plains aussi une et jacques quoi une et
jacques pas trop cuite
oui c'est super ça fera 2 euros 40 s'il
vous plaît à entonner garder la [ __ ]
c'est pour le mois allez au revoir au
revoir
[Applaudissements]
merci d'avoir attendu
vous êtes engagés on se fait la bise
monsieur le premier ministre nous avons
un problème
le nombre de morts à la guerre explose
le plancher nous craignons une
disparition totale de la population
d'ici jeudi
j'ai une idée on va passer une loi pour
interdire la mort à la guerre ok
premières mesures du gouvernement pour
résorber la mort à la guerre faire
semblant pour nous comprendre la
situation regardons ensemble le sujet de
gibles seychelles
depuis la mise en vigueur de cette loi
le visage de la guerre a bien changé
hier on pouvait voir des champs de
bataille rempli le sens de membres
arrachés ou encore de vie chère à même
le sol
aujourd'hui tout cela n'est qu'un
lointain sony toi même la torture ont
une meilleure tournure à passer à table
sale fils de chien jamais trop tard
j'allais ici maintenant tout ce qui
tâche c'est la boue non ce relou c'est
relou j'en ai marre ça va c'est le
premier ministre nous avons encore un
problème comme les gens ne meurent plus
à la guerre nous connaissons une hausse
démographique sans précédent
j'ai une idée on va enterrer nos morts
pour de fonds pour de vrai hockey
ok je ne suis pas vraiment décédé j'y
peux rien c'est les ordres je ne suis
pas mort en fait excuser - battle oui
est ce que vous savez où je peux trouver
du sperme quoi c'est pour faire un nuage
de sperme dans maps is as we are we know
it no mercy sa capuche j'aime beaucoup
votre tee shirts et beaucoup de boue
merci vous aussi merci merci à tous ceux
qui ont participé à cette émission et
excusez moi mais est ce que vous auriez
une éprouvette par hasard une éprouvette
ouais une éprouvette qu'est-ce que
détient une éprouvette ou un récipient
en finale alors vous vous n'aviez pas
d'éprouvettes
alors vous avez tous mis dans la bouche
et vous étiez garée en double file
oui tu perds tu peux quand même super
bien le mec qui a du sperme dans la
bouche
oui c'est parce que j'ai une foi alors
c'était le golden shoe numéro 8 me
faisais messieurs merci à tous
on se retrouve pour le collège chauny
neogaf
l'entente airs l'applaudît
merci les choses
ça
clermont
[Musique]
et m